We drove to the beach
with the mission of
building a full sized
ping pong table
completely out of sand...
I think we're ready in like 2 hours
I think
This is already a good start!
I'm not sure how playable it will be
We're gonna find a way to make it work!
This is going to be
a mission
Looks like a
body or something...
Three guys with a bunch of spades
and buckets
On a beach
And looking at that
It's really suspicious
I have to say
And more buckets!
This is the sand we want!
Oh yeah!
Already starting to regret this
idea a bit
World's biggest sand ping pong table:
Newlywed couple!
That's a good shot though!
Getting more and more
optimistic all the time!
It's good to hear that!
I'd say
only 7 hours left!
Guys!
we’re out here on the beach
building something absolutely ridiculous!
So please do us a favor.
We're trying to reach 5 million,
and we're going to make the world's
largest chocolate table tennis racket.
So please help us out and subscribe!
This reminds me of the
ice table
It's the exact same process.
It is. It is.
It has to be tightly packed!
Does it look like a ping pong table?
Not yet!
We're making gradual progress
Otto’s stomping the sides
to make it more solid
We're building
a massive ping pong table
out of sand
Do you want to help us?
No!
Looks like a lot of work!
Miikka that was
A for effort!
You guys want to help?
Sure!
Thank you!
So many dogs!
Come get me!
When we first started making
YouTube videos
I never thought it would
lead to me
being in L.A.
Shoveling sand...
Carving process has begun here
It's like a big birthday cake
What’s your channel?
Pongfinity
I’ll subscribe!
This is worth a subscription!
Definitely
You guys heard it!
This is worth a subscription!
Is it an ancient Mayan temple?
Correct!
It's supposed to be a ping pong table
Oh all right...
There’s a lot of curious people
I watched you guys on YouTube this morning!
You did?
No way!
We have our helper
what's your name?
Jayden
Oh, that looks delicious!
What a soup!
Now it's looking like a table!
guys
I found a stick!
That actually works!
We have to try if it's Emil solid!
So we're marking the edges
with some tape
It's very primitive
6 hours of work
It all comes down to this
The moment of truth
Does the ball bounce?
Otto
Let’s go!
I actually got it!
Net serve!
Oh, no Emil you broke it!
It’s still in play!
What’s going on?
Still in play!
This rally is getting out of hand
There's nothing left of the table anymore
All in all, it works!
Subscribe down below!